now chris rock and will smith made
amends or is their feud only just
beginning rocks words post slap might
give us some indication the bizarre 94th
academy awards ceremony remains in the
news almost solely because of the
strange altercation between will smith
and chris rock it's hard to imagine that
anyone on the internet has not seen the
footage of smith striding on stage to
slap rock in response to the comedian's
g.i jane joke about jada pinkett smith's
alopecia what started as a shocking
moment in live television broadcast
history has turned into a fairly serious
moment for the academy at large now the
organization is conducting a formal
review of the incident people magazine
reported that abc and academy producers
discussed removing smith from the dolby
theater in los angeles after the
incident however smith was allowed to
return to his seat both he and jada
appeared to be in good spirits when the
show's broadcast resumed in fact footage
even showed smith speaking with denzel
washington tyler perry and his publicist
during the commercial break after that
smith stayed in his seat until he was
announced as a winner of the best actor
award for his performance in king
richard it's a lot of emotion it's
probably all welling up in him right now
rock for his parts has now spoken
publicly since he left the stage on
sunday night but based on what he
reportedly said to oscar's crew members
and other presenters during his exit it
sounds like he tried to maintain a sense
of humor about the situation according
to vanity fair's live reporting from the
oscars rock continued to play off the
altercation by cracking a joke about
will smith's role as muhammad ali in the
2001 biopic ali is particularly notable
in smith's career as it was the first
role for which he received a nomination
for an academy award rock reportedly
told crew and other oscar's presenters
after he exited the stage that's the
only time you get hit by muhammad ali
and it doesn't leave a scratch during
sunday night's telecast smith offered an
apology to the academy and to the show's
audience when he accepted his oscar for
best actor however he did not offer a
public apology to rock for the incident
until monday on his instagram account
smith acknowledged that he was
embarrassed by his actions and sorry for
resorting to violence smith wrote i
would like to publicly apologize to you
chris i was out of line and i was wrong
well rock reportedly declined to press
charges against smith the comedian has
not offered any public comments since he
left the stage during the show
meanwhile sean diddy combs told page six
of the vanity fair after party that
smith and rock had made amends however
the same outlet clarified that combs
spoke individually with smith and ruck
and that the two had not actually spoken
one-on-one since the altercation chris
rock's remark after getting slapped
seems to indicate he's taking the
incident in his stride while plenty of
people online condemned will smith's
actions others weren't so quick to take
aside comedian patent oswald posted
several choice tweets about the slap
comedic actor diedrick bader also got in
on the phone taking to twitter to write
as a minor celebrity i feel like i have
27 to 30 hours to do anything i want and
no one will notice but it wasn't just
comedians who saw the lighter side of
the situation pennsylvania
representative malcolm kenyatta showed
no one knows his state better than him
when he wrote will smith smacking chris
rock and questlove winning an oscar are
the two most back-to-back filly things
to ever happen at the oscars
and those are just a few of the
reactions from public figures the rest
of the general public has done what they
do best in these scenarios and that's
turned the event into a meme in the
aftermath of the slap numerous people
have made some variation of the joke
paper beats rock in reference to smith
using an open hand to hit rock it's only
natural for some people to use humor to
defuse a tense situation as chris rock
probably knows all too well check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you